the best journalism includes balance
inclusion of all perspectives and a
clear-headed presentation of the facts
but not everyone agrees with that these
days this is what we all got in the
business to do
is that journalism is not a profession
of being friends
journalism is a profession of agitation
these words came in response to the
philadelphia inquirer
the paper recently published an opinion
piece buildings matter
too opposing the looting and destruction
of historic buildings during protests
44 journalists who were later backed by
jamel
hill stood in opposition to the
publication of this op-ed
the editor-in-chief was forced to
apologize and
resign the philadelphia inquirer
published a headline in tuesday's
edition that was deeply offensive
we should not have printed it we're
sorry and regret that we did
we also know that an apology on its own
is not sufficient
philadelphia enquirer editor-in-chief
stan wichnowski whose team
won a pulitzer prize back in the day is
not the only one to recently resign
the new standards of journalism are
forcing others out the door as well
for example james bennett editor of the
new york times
he was forced out the door after
staffers opposed his publication
of an op-ed by u.s senator tom cotton
that advised the use of the army against
rioters last week we saw a significant
breakdown in our editing processes
not the first we've experienced in
recent years both of us concluded that
james would not be able to lead the team
through the next
leg of change that is required so where
does all of this lead
it's not only watch what you write but
also watch who you know
as you can no longer be associated with
anyone who's not actively involved in
supporting these protests
texts to relatives and loved ones
telling them you will not be visiting
them or answering phone calls
until they take significant action in
supporting black lives
either through protest or financial
contributions
and now it's watch what you read stop
studying books that might reinforce your
prejudices
have you considered that if you identify
as white and read only the work of white
authors
you are in some ways listening to an
extension of your own voice on repeat
while the details and depth of
experience may differ
white voices have dominated what has
been considered canon for ian's
that means non-white readers have had to
process stories and historical events
through a white
author's lens to some these new
standards of journalism controlling
thought and action
might come across as more dangerous than
state censorship
but those promoting them make no
apologies
caleb maupin rt new york
legal and media analyst lionel believes
that these events show that the public
itself is now limiting free speech
since when is journalism determined by
consensus since when do you poll your
employees
to make sure that not only do you have
to
gear your message to comport with the
world view of your subscribers
but then you have to tweak it and make
sure it
fits to what your employees
feel what we're seeing right now is
we're seeing
citizen vigilantism
it's not the thought police but the
thought vigilantes
people individual citizens who want to
limit opinion
either through newspapers social media
name it and again my beloved
constitution
has nothing to say about this because
this only limits
the government from limiting it and
what's happening
is the bigger problem americans are
becoming so used to so conditioned so
habituated to this kind of limitation of
speech
and they don't notice it anymore they
say well maybe
so what if they weren't limited that's
the problem